A SHOT.TARS BENCH.
>> HERE IS JAMIE DOWN THE RIGHT
SIDE, WHAT'SCK GETS THROUGH, ANS
DANGER.
>> COMING ON GOAL.
THE BLUES ARE TRYING TO GET
BINNINGT LINE.
KIVIRANTA FLIES IN, ALONG SHOT.
GLOVE SAVE BY BINNINGTON.
NO HIGH PUT SHOT BY BUCHNEVICH,.
KRUG FOR PERRON.
SHOOTS AT ON GOAL, AND ONE
MIGHT BUY SPEED 20.
A SHOT BY BROWN ON GOAL, AND A
SAVEN GOAL.
WE GET THE WHISTLE AS HE GETS
HIS MASK.
GOOD PICKED UP -- THAT IS OFF B.
SHOOTS PARTIAL BREAK FOR
PERRON.
LOST THE HANDLE.
>> THAT IN
PRACTICE, ESPECIALLY AGAINST A
TEAM LIKE THIS ARE SO DALLAS.
>> YOU CAN HEAR THAT THOUGHT ON
OH, I SEE WHAT HAPPENED.
THE PARKEN,
DENIED BY SAVEENT, BIG ANGLE
THE RECORD WHEN LEADING AFTER
TWO IS 10.
1-1.
THE BLUES TO 55.
>> WHAT A SAVE BY HOLTBY!
THAT WAS THE
GOALTENDER IS ALREADY LEANING
TOWARDS THAT.
YOU SEE THE WAY
SCHENN AND KYROU.
WHAT A
GET HIMSELF BACK IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NET AFTER THIS PLAY.
AMAZINGLY SO, BECAUSE THAT BATT.
KYROU RACES INTO THE
KYROU LEANS RIGHT INTO
HEISKANEN.
THIS IS A P P
>> THIS IS A BIG TIME IN THE
GAME. WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DEFENSEMEN BLOCKED
HIM OUT.
THAT WAS THAT SAVE APPLAUSE]THA.
THE CHIN